it's a culinary hotspot in the central
market of buenos aires and people here
pride themselves in cooking the best
spanish tortillas in the city
but with the country's inflation rate at
50 percent
patricia rodriguez says she has to make
an extra effort each month to keep the
business going argentina
argentina is a disorganized country but
we learn to serve the situation it's a
constant challenge and a learning
experience our products have very good
quality i don't want to reduce our
quality so what i do is try to sell as
much as i can so i gain in quantity and
don't have to increase the price as much
the government has been trying to
regulate the rising prices with controls
and other economic measures but it has
not succeeded
inflation has been a problem for
argentines for decades and that's why
people implement strategies to protect
their income in this market for example
butchers meet once a month to agree on
the price of certain cuts and they
promote those prices in cardboards like
this one the problem we're told that
this month the price of beef went up
around seven percent so now they have to
change these cardboards once again
jose luisa owns a butcher shop
since the pandemic beef consumption has
dropped significantly and he's still
trying to recover from the economic
impact
the beef culture in argentina is huge
with barbecues every weekend what we see
is people not eating as much beef like
before and they are eating pork and
chicken instead
inflation forces the government to
guarantee that salaries and pensions
increase to keep up with a constant
rising prices
protests like this one show it does not
always work
on tuesday thousands gathered in the
center of buenos aires to demand more
government assistance
argentina and the international monetary
fund are in financial talks to negotiate
more than 40 billion in debts to target
inflation
but economies say the fight to control
rising prices won't be easy
in argentina there are several factors
that have an impact on inflation that's
why it's so difficult to tackle it
unless there is an integral plan that
attacks all those causes of inflation
it's like a monster with a thousand
heads argentines have gotten used to
living with inflation and many have
found ways to survive it but it's a
vicious cycle that has hurt the
country's chances of growth argentines
have gotten used to living with
inflation and many have found ways to
survive it but it's a vicious cycle that
has hurt the country's chances of
achieving
long-lasting economic growth teresa al
jazeera buenos aires